I think it's appalling they while
animals there it's outdated outmoded
it's a rubbish for me falling dead this
is where I do all the work with the
animals follow me in 25 year old Thomas
Chipperfield
is from a family of lion tamers his dad
did it his granddad did it and he says
it's in his blood
I've got sale ID shoes to fill more than
anything else that doesn't mean that
I've got a natural right to do anything
I've got to earn my year my place should
be right the animals have always been
very very good there was an occasion in
Northern Ireland when I was working over
there with the the generator supplying
power to the the show just failed
completely it wasn't a matter of a trip
going off it was the generator shut down
I was in the middle of rolling one of my
Tigers over she was right in front of me
just as close as where you are now to me
and they would have been able to see me
because their night vision is excellent
and they would have been able to see
that I couldn't see them so if they
wanted to do something that would have
been their opportunity and they would
have seized it we'll just close these
knees up and then would be ready to go
Thomas is now gonna do his training does
this every day with all of his animals
brings them in while it's quiet and make
sure they're up to speed on all the
different routines and commands there
they are there there's two lions I can
see
come on salvo all right good boy Sabo on
your place only place a local boy asagai
only place for boys ups our local boys
cassava chicken chicken come on here
quick yeah yes our quick come here come
here come around here quick
well you just lost that up sit up side
but good boy shut up asagai sit up
asagai sit up salvage that up quick
pastor guy sit up a spice it up alright
good boys tell us why you were training
there I'll be completely honest with you
I found it thrilling my heart was racing
but also I didn't enjoy the experience
you didn't enjoy the experience I was I
was more worried about you than I was
enjoying the actual spectacle of what I
was seeing
do you finally get that response from
people no people really to seem to enjoy
it they sin - wow that's sir that's
amazing what you can do with these guys
how well you can work with when you're
in the cage they're even here you can
really sense the power these lions and
tigers have got do you not think they
should be unleashing that do you not
feel sometimes you just want to let them
run these guys do run in here they do
play in here they do exert their energy
what you saw is ample exercise for them
to have superior cardiovascular health -
what zoo animals have and I've been told
that by a zoo vet very recently although
the circus has all the right paperwork
to tour whales Thomas was refused a
license to operate in England the
Department for Environment Food and
Rural Affairs said the big cat sleeping
area was too small they didn't refuse us
they just said that we have to it was
rejected though wasn't it that's the
refusal and it wasn't rejected Lee they
gave us recommendations in order to move
forward to obtain the license but then
the time for the application ran out and
they said we'll have to start the
process again because there's a time
limit issue on it wasn't an actual
refusal it was you have to meet these
recommendations to get the license the
same rules don't apply in Wales so this
summer the Lions have been touring town
to town
the latest stop is this small village
called Tana near Neath in South Wales
this is one of the last places that the
circus tools in Wales this season and
next season's future is uncertain what
do you think of that you know the fact
that the lion shows here I don't think
it's suitable entertainment for
youngsters today I think you know
there's far more interesting things for
them to see and do and it just seems
cruel old isn't it to keep the animals
locked in cages we think that gays are
we concerned I think it's absolutely
appalling I gather so I gather only
through my wife that in Scotland is
banned is that correct no it's not
banned anywhere in the country anyway in
the country well I've got my information
wrong well it's about time the British
government did banning wild animals in
circuses has been a political hot potato
for many years the last government
promised to ban it as does this one but
for over a year they've issued a similar
statement saying it will happen as soon
as parliamentary time allows now faced
with increasing pressure here in Wales
the Welsh government has decided to act
alone and is looking into whether or not
to ban it themselves don't you feel that
you're in a situation where the public
opinion just isn't with you anymore and
this is this is now out of fashion just
like other things to do with animals I
don't know badger baiting cockfighting
these things that used to be perfectly
acceptable and perfectly popular just
aren't around anymore do you think this
is the way it's going well yeah I don't
think so at all as I've said to you
already it's we've it's a case that
we've actually had a lot of support from
people everywhere we've gone and the
examples of outdated traditions that
you've just mentioned they were all
outlawed based on welfare concerns there
are no welfare concerns with what we're
doing at the minute the opposition to
what we're doing is purely ideological
there are three wild animal circuses
left in Britain Thomas and his team are
the only ones with big cats and they say
keeping the show on the road is as much
about campaigning for their way of life
as making a living Thomas and his family
are well used to the abuse and scrutiny
they get wherever they go they get
protesters petitions and politicians
calling for them to stay
up and in some cases even get death
threats I hope you're disgusting and
cruel regime is bombed out of existence
4:30 p.m. and as the doors open the
guests begin to arrive as do the
protesters it's really cool what they're
doing with the circus animals they're
making animals perform a natural act by
way of cruelty to make them do it so I
did I felt like I have to come out how
do you respond to the fact that there
has been any welfare issues related to
the animals in all the inspections that
have been taking place this and the
other zoos using wild animals the Defra
all the inspectors the animals are well
and that they've been fed and that's it
they don't the end of the day any animal
needs a large amount of space which they
don't have the RSPCA are not happy with
the fact that being moved the way
they're transported I understand that
about 95 percent of public is against
the circus and abuse of animals like
this it's unnecessary these days there
are still people who are coming in here
and paying their money not very many not
very many
there are more people paying to go in
there than there are protesters
amongst the team Thomas's dad Tommy
waits for Showtime people say we're
Victorian I suppose a lot of these these
demonstrators call it a Victorian but
then so is horse-racing
rules and regulations keep everything in
line and that's all we ask for just to
be regulated we do whatever has to be
done to make sure the animals are well
cared for this is a typical Saturday
teatime show around 90 people turned up
to the venue it can take 200 the
lion-taming section lasts around 15
minutes with short wildlife talks before
and after
then it's out to see the Tigers up close
wonderful show magnificent creatures
both the lions and tigers I think there
should be more to be honest if the
people outside that come in it's just a
lot feel bad I can understand them
protesting there are polls that say you
know that 90% of people in this country
don't want wild animals used in circuses
you think the polls are wrong do you
think people do want this yeah that's
about to come today but not everyone was
happy with what they saw I do think the
enclosure is a little small to be honest
I mean where was the size of a tiger I
wouldn't want to live in that space for
the rest of my life yet you still paid
the money and come along today does that
make you feel guilty in a way or yeah
the Tour of Wales is almost over
after a scramble to find a land owner
willing to host them Thomases next stop
is Swansea they're already waiting for
him with the same mixture the Wonder and
contempt his experience your family's
been doing this for a long time but
we're at the stage now where you're
being described as Britain's last lion
tamer do you think that's the case well
we don't know what the future holds if
we keep going the way we are then my
children will be able to carry on in my
footsteps but it's hard to tell what the
future hold